this is what the invisibility cloak in
Harry Potter was made
Thank You Batman to Black Manta then I
know it's black like that's about it
really
it's watch me the world's blackest
material and I'm like what's that
yeah blackest thing I've ever seen are
these socks I'm wearing today I'm
imagining like flubber and it moves and
it comes and like fights you - I'm like
nervous I'm expecting when I turn this
around something will be black 3 2 1 I
thought I always like to think through
it I'm not able to see the creases of
the foil essentially so it looks like
it's just like a rip in space like this
is exists and this exists and the middle
black bit doesn't know anything so here
you can like totally see it
and then here it's just like yeah I
can't see any texture in it at all so
can you make outfits out of this you're
just two-dimensional where you're
wearing clothes you can see creases
shadows what great how to read about fit
in comparison my socks now we're very
very very dark blue so this is the
blackest commercial paint that you can
buy this is flocking it's used to line
telescopes to stop stray light this is
the Fanta black okay we put it over this
one there's a big reflection over that
one you can definitely see you can see
relation we put over this one and like
if an actual black hole this is the
blackest paint that you can buy it's
pretty much great it's almost white I
want to compare really quick to my yoga
pants which I haven't I think it's crazy
how reflectively I like this black about
to take it back is if you imagine like
your ex-girlfriend your ex-boyfriends
harp it's just as black as their no
random like I guess is hydrophobic which
means that it basically hates water
now we're gonna basically pour water on
it
then see what happens it looks like it's
gonna be fun I'm just fine it's gonna
like bounce off she's rejecting it yeah
yeah it's like Superman and bullets just
does not give it yeah this is the
ultimate clothing material like you'd
never get it where you'd never have to
either and also you'd be invisible so
like if you had this on a car like what
you never have to wash it like you could
just put it on anything that you want to
not get wet like electronics like
there's not even little droplets oh my
god they should make that in like
toilets I didn't expect it to be so pure
looking just completely like flat like
no texture at all how much is vantablack
hour by thumb we're getting the
impression it's more than we can afford
it nevermind okay I'm gonna say
officially that did blow my mind this
would be the best Halloween costume on
the planet and I'd be in this oh my gosh
yes this is great
that's that track suit yeah